le modèle de joe biden avait commencé
avec cette image une pile de dossiers
sur le bureau ovale pour autant de
décret pris en urgence le président
démocrate veut aller vite et le montre
certaines mesures exécutif que je vais
signer aujourd'hui vont contribuer à
inverser le cours de la crise de
qu'ovide nous allons combattre le
changement climatique comme de nous
l'avons jamais fait jusqu'ici et faire
progresser les kits et raciales soutenir
les autres communautés mal desservies
nous allons également reconstruire notre
économie
365 jours plus tard les nuages se sont
accumulés au dessus de la maison blanche
la lune de miel aura été de courte durée
les sondages se suivent et montre une
dégringolade de la popularité du
président démocrate moins d'un américain
sur deux approuve désormais la politique
de joe died
[Musique]
ce fut le dossier le plus délicat pour
joe biden cette année le retrait des
troupes américaines d'afghanistan
une situation chaotique
une évacuation confuse et des images qui
ont choqué le monde entier au coeur de
l'été le président américain a connu de
sérieuses turbulences le tournant
stratégique de la diplomatie américaine
ne se fait pas sans heurts mais joe
biden assume
en ce qui concerne la politique
étrangère qui a guidé notre nation au
cours des deux dernières décennies nous
devons apprendre de nos erreurs pour moi
il y en a deux qui sont primordiales
premièrement nous devons définir des
missions avec des objectifs clairs et
réalisables et non des objectifs que
nous n'atteindrons jamais et
deuxièmement nous devons rester
clairement sont centrés sur l'intérêt
fondamental de la sécurité nationale des
états unis d'amérique
traduction washington va recentrer sa
stratégie sur pékin même s'il s'en
défend joe biden a participé à ce climat
de guerre froide entre les deux grandes
puissances une stratégie qui se fait
même au détriment de la france le plus
vieil allié des états unis poignardé
dans le dos par l'oncle sam dans la
désormais célèbre affaire des sous
marins conséquence une des pires crises
diplomatiques entre les deux pays pour
la première fois de l'histoire paris
rappelle son ambassadeur aux états unis
et c'est l'image d'un président
rassembleur qui s'abîme pour joe biden
[Musique]
c'était la priorité de son début de
mandat lutter contre la pandémie de
covin 19 joe biden s'était montré
particulièrement virulent contre son
prédécesseur sur ce sujet l'accusant
régulièrement de laxisme sauf qu'en un
an le bilan du président démocrate n'est
guère plus reluisant ces mesures d'
obligation de vaccination ont été
contestés en justice et la maison
blanche n'a pas anticipé la faiblesse
des capacités de test dans le pays
résultat le nombre de morts continue
d'augmenter la promesse d'un changement
de doctrine avec donald trump semble ne
pas avoir porté ses fruits
[Musique]
bilan nuancé pour joe biden à
l'intérieur de ses frontières à son
crédit l'économie américaine a repris
des couleurs la maison blanche se
félicite notamment des bons indicateurs
en matière d'emploi mais c'est dans les
couloirs du congrès américain que le
président a rencontré cette année les
plus grandes difficultés seul le premier
volet de son plan d'investissement
historique a été adoptée les réformes
sociales et environnementales sont
toujours bloqués par des divisions
intestines à la peine pour fédérer son
propre camp joe biden doit aussi faire
face à une opposition bien décidé à
retrouver une majorité
le revers dans l'élection du gouverneur
en virginie a sonné comme un sérieux
avertissement alors que les élections de
mi-mandat se profile à l'automne
[Musique]
en un an joe biden aura donc toucher aux
limites d'une campagne électorale axée
essentiellement sur la critique ne son
prédécesseur sur la forme évidemment joe
biden tranche avec donald trump moins
volcanique joe biden est aussi beaucoup
plus discret il est le président qui
s'est le moins présenté face à la presse
depuis ronald reagan le démocrate qui
fêtera ses 80 printemps cette année
encore fort à faire pour les trois
années qui l'attendent si ce n'est
davantage joe biden affirme déjà à qui
veut l'entendre qu'il sera candidat à sa
propre succession en 2024